there's been growing outrage among
people who have heard about this and
many people haven't heard about this
about a series of airstrikes on Mosul
Iraq that appears to have left anywhere
from 100 to 200 civilians dead although
it's it's unclear exactly how many
different airstrikes and locations add
up to the total death toll this was a
us-led coalition which has confirmed
that they hit a vehicle filled with
explosives on March seventeenth and
separately that they're reviewing a
number of different airstrikes that took
place around those dates but we do not
yet have a confirmed death toll there's
an ongoing investigation into this
numerous sources have been on the ground
there and have corroborated the story
that yes there are civilian bodies
everywhere including women and children
although the exact number were still not
clear on it could be a hundred and
thirty the Iraqi military says that 61
confirmed bodies have been pulled and
that there are 50 60 more remaining to
be sort of added to the official tally
the LA Times reporter Molly Hennessey
Fisk visited the area with a civil
defense group a few days ago and told
CNN that she saw at least 50 dead bodies
and body parts in the rubble in addition
to the official count of bodies already
pulled it's horrible it's tragic and
we're going to be focusing on that
aspect of it extensively but here's
what's not being discussed whatever the
number ultimately is this is what Trump
promised this is a promise that Donald
Trump made and is keeping remember when
Donald Trump said the following the
correct war well we see other thing is
with the terrorists you have to take out
their families would you get these
terrorists you have to take out their
families they care about their lives
don't kid yourself which they say they
don't care about the less you have to
take out their family that was not the
only time Donald Trump said something
like that but they mention the family's
going after the families what is that
what does that mean hell I would were
after well at least I would certainly go
after the wives who absolutely knew what
was happening and I guess your
definition of what I do I'm going to
leave that to your imagination
but i will tell you i would be very
tough on families because the families
know what's happening this is what that
looks like this is what Trump voters
voted for we all knew when Trump said
that Pat that that was going to lead to
innocent people being killed when you go
after the families a very haphazard
approach you end up with tons of people
dying many of whom are totally innocent
so far and this is horrible Trump's big
accomplishment or at least his most
notable promise kept is bombing innocent
civilians I wonder if the Trump
supporters like this I genuinely don't
know Trump has not followed through on
basically any other campaign promise
except killing women and children that
may or may not have any connection
whatsoever to terrorists it's absolutely
sickening to hear him say that and our
buddy over at secular talk Kyle kolinsky
actually talks about this yeah and he
says that Democrats should have made
this a bigger point in the election
because just the focus on Donald Trump's
temperament wasn't really enough this is
something that's so horrific that it
affects most people and pretty much
everyone's against this right well I
don't know that's the question I mean
where are the Trump supporters who are
saying yeah I yeah I voted for this
insofar as Trump told me he was going to
do this and I voted for him even if I
didn't like this particular particular
thing and I know we joke about blame
Obama Obama Obama Obama Obama is being
blamed for this by some committed
trumpets I know you're probably thinking
how could how how is that possible the
argument that some Trump supporters are
making is that Obama loosened some of
the rules of engagement in his last
months in office to make it easier to go
after Isis in Iraq so therefore this is
all Obama's fault folks Trump is under
no obligation to take advantage of any
loosening of rules that President Obama
may have done to go and kill dozens of
civilians part of personal
responsibility is not blaming everything
on the prior president this is the exact
opposite of responsibility and again
Trump said he would do this and now he
is and i'm waiting for Trump supporters
to denounce it and we criticized Obama
for the drone strikes and the civilian
casualties but the difference is i think
when Obama was informed that civilians
may have perished he would be actually
upset about this and then by that we do
better Donald Trump it seems like that
was his goal the whole time
yeah i mean i don't know i don't know
how upset obama was and we were we were
tough on obama about the drone strikes
so I don't want to minimize that at all
but what we do know is Trump for example
with that yet but the botched Yemen raid
which led to 30 civilian deaths and the
death of an American Navy SEAL he
approved that casually over dinner with
I think it was madis and jared kushner
or whatever wasn't even bothered to be
in the situation room for it so Trump
promised this here is a campaign promise
Trump is keeping that he is going to be
bombing innocent civilians and he is
doing it big Lee